come on Google all right and we are live
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 54 and it's another
glorious Sunday and we are back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got Nintendo Direct and
inside Xbox presentations to discuss so
we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a Lord who is not
only critical to the vitality of the
gaming industry but in my opinion
represents the few to truly have a
finger on the pulse of the culture this
Lord is a true gamer who was extremely
personable down-to-earth and it is
always a pleasure to hit his informative
viewpoints on both the super-deformed
games cast and the basement radio arcade
podcast introducing the United States
videogames industry analyst of the
iconic NPD Group the lord of precise
analytics detailed industry trends and
the man responsible for getting overly
sensitive fanboys and their feelings
everyone making his debut into the realm
of the Lord's loving Lord that
piscatella how're you doing sir
holy cow you're the realm of the Lords
absolutely which you do really just make
sure works a huge huge fan I love to
dated to the SD GC and grab and always
respect your viewpoints very very solid
man really appreciate you a pleasure to
have you
absolutely and of course we have the
Four Horsemen of gaming those usual
suspects at the roundtable my co-hosts
with the co most my brother from another
mother will be joining us soon in
progress but of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord
the solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
Lord of the seats this is the offline
profile Illuminati love it
Lord sovereign how are you doing sir
doing good man glad to be at at least
75% you know I was still sounding
horrible yesterday and the funny thing
is like last Sunday after the show like
I just kept going downhill to the point
I thought white girls like that we gotta
go is horse I'm not feeling too great
and so you know they do a slew of tests
or whatever they're like yeah um so you
have walking pneumonia in addition to
that in addition to walking you haven't
a throat infection and infection okay so
I'm on the cusp of death yeah so yeah I
have all the drugs yeah I'm good to go
my eyes open I said what the heck we're
glad to have you back in the ground
Lord's healthy and no no hopefully
pneumonia free and of course we have the
excess gamer oh the lord of combat
sports who was a man of his convictions
demands nothing less than that premium
experience it is the tiki torch
extinguisher Oh beloved Lord King how
you doing sir oh do you understand how
good I'm feeling to date the boxing gods
sure prays last night over these two
combat individuals now you know you had
a lot of combat going on last night I'm
just going to get to the cusp of the
fantastic fight that you had in front of
you
what do you buy guess who again now hey
man is show time like so you're lying I
know you playing this year they're not
playing this year they're putting butts
in seats and getting that heart racing
now let me tell you something about
Sergei you flipping Jets all right now
Sergei Alypius was fighting Mikey Garcia
Mikey Garcia was a 20 to 1 favorite you
couldn't tell Sergei lipids at this
because he was the champion do you
understand
he went to Texas to fight Mikey and
Mikey's backyard balls on this kid his
he was a 20 I think 22 years old young
kid and I could do nothing but root for
this kid because I saw it in his face
when everybody's in the stadium is
against you he's like it's like you're
in the road right a lot of heart
they said his name they said the
champions that he's a champion they said
his name and he got boo his wife was
there she was in hostile territory for
husband
you paid knowledge and they asked man
you know why because they tugged at my
heartstrings this boy was there was a
rocky moment he was gonna have and he
was up against an exceptional talent and
Mikey Garcia and Mikey Garcia did not
let anyone in that stadium down these
guys pitched the war I'm telling you
they pitched the wall of a forth back
and forth
that's right that's right there was
hitting each other with punches that was
so beautiful they were hit each other at
the same time it was it was insane it
was just Mikey's an exceptional talent
lippies jets was trained and is trained
by the great buddy McGirt I asked funny
I remember buddy McGirt why we stopped
you at my age I had to show wifey what
buddy McGirt look like you understand
and this man he's the essence of boxing
and he passed his DNA on to this kid and
this kid look like a Russian buddy
McGirt I got a watch [ __ ] hotel about
you you've sold me you saw me last time
you put me on the air Oh Spence yes
definitely what sovereign dude do you
get the cosine do I get the cosine like
this kid came in there and yeah Mikey is
coming up in weight class um
Mikey you know his power is unproven at
at 140 so you just didn't know how it
was gonna translate and initially it
looked like he was gonna be I mean he
was tested regardless he possessed it
and but this kid was absolutely the
reincarnation of buddy McGirt he really
was he really was and it was fantastic
to see Mikey press like that um because
again it's gonna open him up to bigger
and bigger fights yes he stole my key
drops the kid both both Mikey and lippy
he had throw left hooks
Mikey's is a little bit sharper hits
them on the chin this is where the
season comes in this is the kid 13 pro
fight all right he has 13 pro fights and
10 knockouts okay so the boy is inland
he's mixing it up with Mikey who has 39
fights with thirty knockouts okay no
losses and both these guys had no losses
and the shoulder on a record my hat is
off to lippy yes let me yes I would like
to tell you sir you were in the building
I was rooting for you I've never give
this much trade this is yeah this is
like its name I try to give my energy
through the TV to the guy knock Mikey
out with one of these good shots I mean
he hit Mikey Mikey nose is exploding
every other round with blood it was such
a great fight and I and I say I look
forward to you young man I look forward
to you going forward I know there's
nothing but great things we his wife got
into the ring she gave her husband such
a passionate kiss at the end because she
was proud of him like I was proud of him
yeah
but he was proud of him and the Watson
community as a whole was greater for
last night shout-out to lipid yets and
the crew and buddy McGirt no doubt do we
have any UFC lastly I'm so sorry
no no whatever it was there was no UFC
last night I don't know there was any
Bellator like that but no no big UFC
stuff so yeah don't be over yourself
next all right so I'm finishing right I
finished the fight and we're watching
Thor Ragnarok after I'm not kissing you
can watch dawn Ragnarok you know daddy's
shootout to work and he'll be right back
yeah all right so we watch some store
Ragnarok mr. two o'clock and I'm like am
you ready get out of here three o'clock
I said what the hell just happened on
the ILP not telling you what you want to
hear or what you need to hear so before
we get into what the Lords are playing
this week I want to start off Lord
piscatella his video game system history
also his journey in the entertainment
software industry for 15 years and of
course what led him to the legendary NPD
Group so uh piscatella let's start from
the beginning was from a gaming
perspective well but kind of like the
first systems you had and what kind of
got you into gaming oh man so my uncle
when I was four years old brought over
like the 2600 I think I'm the day came
out he fired up asteroids on that thing
and then I whoa
I was pretty much done I'm like yeah
yeah I want it I want all of it
and then really when I finally got one
and so I getting the pitfall and star
Raiders and uh and a kaboom man like I
was dreaming done classics yeah that was
that was my start in gaming played pong
at the original bar that was in San
Francisco where it was put up for the
first time like in 70 must have been 70
677 somewhere in there when I was like
three or four man I've been a big fan of
games beginning was the first right yeah
first home system yeah and I was pretty
much sold after that that's apparently
according to some people in the
government I should be out you know
doing bad things but have fun and hang
out and be groovy and in a positive way
right I mean I don't know and then I
found my way after working for Banana
Boat suntan lotion for a while and
working on some dog food analysis I was
working at pedigree you know analyzing
those 16 ounce cans of lamb wet yeah I
didn't submit to Activision as Laura
laughter yeah we're worth it well I had
six jobs in six years I worked in sales
planning trade marketing retail planning
long range forecasting everything with
basically a revenue number so did I
think my first game I worked on was
Shrek 2
oh wow and then all the way through like
Guitar Hero the Call of Duty era and all
that fun stuff
nice nice head over then headed over to
Warner for like the last eight or nine
years as a vice president I was planning
over there with man in mortal combat in
Scribblenauts and Lego and all that fun
stuff Wow very cool they're too big to
bigger entities now my question I just
want to bring you back just a little bit
because I got a I got to get the history
so from the 2600 where did you progress
system wise give me back the next like
almost chronological order for you from
the from a console perspective all right
so 2600 and the Dreamcast for like a
minute yes the NES where I was a contra
and blades of Steel guy
and I built my first gaming PC around 96
ok at the same time I got into Genesis
in NHL 93 94
wait a minute you talk an iconic NHL's
now you took it took it bad for and dad
like that that's you that actually had
bill still along to show it that's what
it was like favorites of all time people
are Glee saying it's the great as I can
ok so there's there's two there's two
schools of thought here right first
there's NHLPA 93 right it wasn't
actually NHL because it wasn't licensed
by there wasn't licensed correct
but it was licensed by the Players
Association so you could actually fight
in NHLPA 93 but an NHL 94 is the more
iconic that was in swingers right yes
yes yeah like there's a lot of
discussion about how NHL 94 is the
greatest hockey game ever made but I
would argue that of hlp a 93 it's still
and and I will I will fight anyone who
we go get bill stay well back with the
show we're gonna have an NHL 93 versus
at each other I love it over at Warner
Brothers we had a we had a big
tournament we had an NHL PA 93
tournament I put on that was a lot of
fun we had like 64 entrants and I had a
blast doing that so yeah I'm a I'm still
I still have a Sega Genesis like that
was a great system now did the Super
Nintendo us sneak in there and I fell
down a PC until not the late or the mid
90s when I picked up 360 and ps3 or
mid-2000s where I picked up a 360 and
ps3 so I never had an n64 okay
ness and then 64 or whatever came out
for that the cube that was pretty much
PC only but gosh but then when I got in
the industry in like 2005 I bought
everything ever since you know you did
bet you the activision blizzard and you
mentioned warner brothers specifically
like any other specific memories
anything that stand out during your run
during those two kind of major entities
yeah there's I mean there's so many
industry so the industry from the
perspective of people that follow it
from like a fan perspective you know
like there's a lot of misconceptions out
there about how publishers are these big
corporate entities full of suits and
everything is science and everyone's
very serious and understands everything
that's going on and they have plans and
big machination really like we're just
the publishers just normal people and
they're hoping that things go right and
sometimes they don't
I made a couple ones that really stand
out to me was the morning after Call of
Duty 2 released on the 360 huge game
yeah it was a huge game but we didn't
know it would be at the time I called it
he won on PC did pretty well but it
wasn't it wasn't Call of Duty right
though
a day after Call of Duty 2 launches you
know and if you remember that was the
game that had the $10 price hike mmm was
the first game launched at 59 and
everyone was really nervous about that
and I got in very early the next day I
was the second person in the office
behind our VP of Sales and I remember
6:15 in the morning she got her first
call from the East Coast saying that
college 82 didn't really well and she
said I think we have a hit and that was
like the beginning I'm really Nolan
movie becoming so yeah that was really
fun
um that's huge yeah yeah stuff like that
was really fun times like when I was at
another meeting where basically they
wanted to make blur the adult version of
Mario Kart that was pretty funny really
yeah that didn't work out so well and
then like when Tony Hawk's ride was
coming out I don't know if you remember
that it was a we were skateboard yeah
it's not a big plastic skateboard
it had Peck in it the time not not Bobby
but microfiche was came over to the area
where it was hanging out and he got on
the board and he almost fell off and
like hit his head
there's so many crazy stories you know
it's just one of those things like you
read the message board post you read
Twitter and they're like oh these gaming
companies they know what they're doing
they're out to screw us and now like you
know sometimes so I was around for
project the project $10 initiative when
that woman I don't remember
Arkham City catalyst was a $10 charge
for people that were buying it used like
we didn't know like it was a it was
didn't have like we were like well maybe
this will work maybe it won't like I
don't know and it didn't work
right some of the fun memories though so
do you think the perception is like no
games today like they almost affect the
evil corporation like did you feel like
I mean we all know this is a
money-making business but do you feel
like it's a you know that gamers have a
misperception you know in reference to
that like they're all out to get them
well some of them are out to get I'm
sure like I know some evils there are
some Machiavelli's out there right like
as there are in any industry there are
people who are trying to get over but
but the vast majority of people want to
do what's right for people like their
game they want to like feel good about
what they're doing they want their
customers are feel really good about
buying stuff and I think the
overwhelming majority of people when
they do things or they create programs
or games like they're trying to make
things that people really like that can
also pay the bills you know absolutely I
mean I appreciate your honesty on that
that's really cool and then lastly in
reference to the young the NPD group you
know that's a huge deal as gamers you
know I know there's gonna be one of my
questions I'll have for you a little
later but on you know it's a huge deal
you know as far as what's going on in
the industry and health with the
industry kind of what led you down that
path to County to link up with them yeah
so I've been doing forecasting and
planning for like 15 years I've worked
on everything from Guitar Hero to Lego
dimensions to skylanders to you know
Call of Duty to mortal comic I've worked
on some of the biggest games in the
world really enjoyed it
but like I miss being able to talk
people at games you know so like there's
this huge secrecy veil across the
industry and you know for many reasons
but you know if you work at a publisher
like you can't talk about anything right
and I wanted to hang out and talk about
videogames of people I wanted to go talk
to retailers I wanted to go talk to
other publishers and share ideas and
talk about what was working and what
wasn't how can we make the games
industry better how can we provide
better products for people how do we do
things in the right way that you know we
meet we focus on the things that can
help grow the business while also being
good to the customer you know so and I'm
gonna join that a lot like I get to like
I just came back from a week where I got
to meet with two major retailers and
four major publishers and voice chat
video games and how to figure out what's
going on because this industry is
freaking weird man and things change
really fast in means you know if you're
not really on top of it and trying to
understand what's going on you're gonna
be left behind a lot of fun absolutely
minute sounds really cool and I'm gonna
ask this quote last question as far as a
gaming history I've been doing this for
a little while now a neat it's gonna be
a tough one
I need your top five video games game
franchises of all time all right okay so
number five I'm gonna call it the the
general series the games like Panzer
General Pacific general okay okay
turn-based world are basically strategic
mass scale games I would put Mario in
that top five I mean Wolfenstein in the
top five old classic I put The Witcher
series in the top five nice and I would
also put the Lego games in the top five
of course I like the Lego games man
they're really fun just to go eat up
some bricks for a while
exactly that's a diverse group I respect
that
I got it gotta respect the top five in
gaming Lord addict entered the room
service to see you know pop in sorry
I've been having a lot of tissues yeah I
know you're not feeling well man good to
good to have you because I was even like
I think I'm just gonna miss IOP today as
like now is like you know we we had a
our guess at least have to show my
respect he's going through wisdom tooth
done so that I know that pinion it's
awful I sound like a squirrel though you
know that's just how it's gonna be
covered through so that's cool
history piscatella um I want to get into
what the Lords are playing this week so
let's start with local sect Ella himself
again what specifically what games
specifically haven't been touching this
week so I've been on a lot of planes and
in a lot of hotel rooms the last few
weeks so I've been I've been saving
Zelda for this time of year about I'm in
my third divine beast I'm really
enjoying the hell out of it I mean all
the superlatives people been talking
about it or true probably about 50 hours
in and I'm just kind of taking my time
and exploring the world and just having
a blast so you have a little behind the
times but that one's taken that's a
great one to save that's a great way to
say no that sounds good let me give her
Lord addict his intro since he may be
limited with the wisdom tooth issue of
course we have my brother from another
mother
my co-host with the cokes the difficult
game Conqueror and the young how what's
going on every time I do something you
just gonna keep adding to my intro any
more superlatives know that what you've
been playing this week but besides
battling the tooth issues nothing
actually started watching the Jessica
John season two yesterday oh yeah I
gotta catch up and I still they finished
Punisher their game wise haven't
anything specific no not really I've
been sleeping for the most part
hey I've been playing pop G okay there
we go
it's solve what have you been playing
this week like I said yesterday's
podcast I've been playing a lot trying
to finish that Mad Max so what I realize
about the Mad Max is that I spent so
much time oh just like getting
everything on the map clearing out the
map and I've totally forgot about the
story elements so mmm
I've done very little story so when I'm
at the end I'm thinking I'm at the end
of the game like not only like the third
act
story-wise so I still have a bunch of
stuff to do but the map is clean though
they allowed me to clean the map up
before I was still grinding away at that
um on the switch I picked up Gora Gora
which is a puzzle game a tile based
puzzle game which is really cool um it's
it's like uh it's perspective based
basically like they're three panels then
they give you like with different like
different like paintings and whatnot and
the thing about it is you have to figure
out how they interact with each other
and they'll create and they kind of give
you hints as to how you move forward so
it becomes like something that the
animates after a while but you have to
figure out how the panels interact with
each other pretty cool game like and I
got it basically for free with my my
gold points so I got and that's pretty
much it you know just still grinding
away slowly but surely out Celeste on
the twist oh my god god bless your soul
we're gonna talk about that direct or
what with the Lords of light Oh Lord
King will you uh oh nine parchment the
trial I'm gonna pick it up I actually
like it I'm gonna pick it up I played a
little bit of Rainbow six siege sinister
[Music]
no you know why because the way the game
was structured it was another structure
for that type of format so for them to
push it into that format it seems like a
chore because the way two enemies they
take their bullet sponges they have to
work on that when it comes to that
because there is overly aggressively
are for absolutely no reason um but they
have to work on that part of it and it
affixed is a good idea
there's good in premise I think if we
have a team of four it actually got a
whole lot better we I was just mean sent
us a plan and then playing super lucky
seal having such a great go with this
what is it the Mario Galaxy one
Conqueror
you know I guess black guys last night
look at your glove King put out that
controversial still is a better game
than mario galaxy one um and of course
you know like I said that pubs you love
that's it no doubt for me it's been uh
oh I mean I realized this week how much
addicted I am necks calm like I have a
problem all right
like X cub is really I'm addicted to it
like it's one of my top franchises and
on since the Xbox when X came out with
that a 4k update for the UM for more of
the chosen specifically there's only
only applies to that DLC it is so
addicting it's very difficult you know I
was talking a lot of piscatella earlier
before we started and it's really
unforgiving like it's really the
hardcore XCOM guy and I had to take some
strategies that add it used to tell me
about you know you kind of focus on your
weapons focus on your armor your squad
size early that kind of stuff but now
I'm starting to make a lot of progress
and this whole little chosen dynamic
really cool you know they have these
specific alien factions and they're
really tough but there's also these
other factions that you align yourself
with on earth that can kind of counter
each one and it's a lot of it's deep I
was I was going in and someone on the
barely getting by this because I walk
because everyone's hurt okay I'm good
I'm good I'm like there's only like
maybe three or four people left
I've inch my way through the map the
assassin pops on why you gotta be
kidding me
they're coming at the end of the mission
you like depleted and you're like oh no
like they come in at the would they
actually were
than the alien rulers DLC from the
standard base game like it's it's it's
mostly like a hardcore XCOM guys like a
love letter to those guys but really
enjoy and shout the deficit gonna check
but I don't do one one view runs away I
don't play the motel which goes live
live but that's pretty much what I've
been playing so we get into last week's
poll so the results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the one-year anniversary of the switch
now upon us what do we feel is the most
important thing for its continued
success in year two the winner at 34% in
a razor close 4-way ILP poll was the
party chat messaging and trophies better
online infrastructure growth so they won
the poll coming in at second place this
is probably closest ever there's one
percent difference on at thirty three
percent was to continue to deliver huge
IPS like smash and Pokemon group third
place at twenty seven percent was the
bring back Virtual Console group and our
shallow fourth place group only six
percent cuz the tender level FTW girl I
mean what can you say about it I mean I
think it goes to show like like who's
talking about the sort of stuff when
you're talking about like the hardcore
guys just want more Nintendo properties
right on on the console and they're
gonna deliver on that right but as you
move forward a lot of these properties
are gonna have a lot of online aspects
to them that you just want to function
properly so it's like yeah it makes
sense that those two categories are so
close together because it's it's open
it's it's kind of a toss-up like you
know Nintendo is gonna give you the
properties at some point right however
long they take to come out you're gonna
see all the major stuff on the switch so
yeah the underlying stuff is what you
want to function properly
so we'll see we'll see piscatella what
do you feel what's your most what you
want for the yes which now come in
did you prefer the online infrastructure
first Virtual Console the bigger bigger
IDs like the smashes and stuff so a
slightly different take
right now the switch is very much a core
gamer box these are user devices that
I've been purchased by folks that I
already have one of the other big
consoles for the most part these are
core gamers that are in the system I
think what's most important for the
switch in this year and beyond is
getting past that core gamer group
getting into the mass market getting mom
for a little Johnny or little Jane that
doesn't have a system yet so it's really
it's about focusing on the family the
kids and and widening that circle and
things like labo or labo or whatever you
want to call it labo will do that but
then also like getting the games like
Kirby and then ultimately Pokemon RPG is
going to do everything that's gonna
change the game but youyou personally
met do you want it was up to do would
you want it just the big titles or ahead
of the the online obstruction you
personally so I'm me personally I'm most
interested to see what they do with
their online service how it incorporates
smash how well they can evolve in the
modern videogame environment now that
they have a really hit system on their
hands how do they maintain momentum and
I think they do that through a number of
ways but yeah personally I want to see
that online that online service be
fantastic value for the money so we'll
see absolutely and widget no it's you
right so what we're gonna start off
these times but we got a little debut a
little segments cuz we got lower
piscatella in the house in the brown you
know we had a little question said
because you know we got to get some
things answered and uh you know as
gamers you know you come in contact with
things that we're very curious about we
love what you do in your industry so um
I'm gonna set off the first question and
we'll pass around to the Lord you know
for more questions for you so the first
one is gonna be like you know although
obviously that the past years in in the
United States by MPD has become like an
extreme point of contention for like
hardcore gamers fanboys are like my
question you love piscatella is like did
you ever think that MPD would kind of
evolve or I don't
like devolve into something fanboys
would become so passionate about like
after the 15th of every month well I
can't I mean like people especially
gamers are competitive by nature
everyone wants their system of choice to
succeed because then they think they'll
get the better games that they better
service is like I get it I think there's
just a misconception of what or how
these companies look at these sales
figures so for example I've been around
like I said a bunch of retailers and a
bunch of publishers recently and
everyone's talking about engagement
they're not talking sales they're
talking about how do we keep people
playing on our platform
what are those Play metrics look like
like I'm giving sales figures and people
are like yeah whatever like but how many
hours how many hours are we getting
right so it's it's a it's a weird thing
so I think the fans or the people online
are take this stuff far more seriously
than a lot of people in the industry to
do and you know I think part of that
part of that problem is because a lot of
the stuff that is put out as pretty
secretive like I can't divulge things
like install bases or shares or after
eighths or anything like that
and that's a bummer right because if we
were able to fill in those blanks then
the arguments wouldn't happen and people
focus on the things that matter which is
the games good point so I try to do my
best in order to help like they I know
that I know when people want to know and
I try to do my best and letting them
know the results of what they want to
know without divulging things I can't
because I want the conversation to be
positive and encouraging and like people
should be excited about the games come
in and seriously like the ps4 Xbox one
thing which is just so obnoxious online
like both systems are doing very well
one system is doing better globally
absolutely but it doesn't mean that
games aren't going to come to one system
of the other or that one system is going
away like these both of these ecosystems
are very healthy and strong creature and
it's going to be just fine Lord addict
do you have any question for a law
office Katella
we got the MPD Lord in here any specific
question oh it's to this out
I do have a question you know since
you're like you know part of the NPD
credit if you ever seen something sell
way more than it did and you were
surprised as generally surprised yeah
all the time
monster hunter world most recently was
was huge I went back and checked that
number three times I'm like are we sure
we're not double counting somewhere
Dragonball Fighters I did the same thing
because it was the best selling game
since Budokai - in 2002 or 2003 so I
mean it happens a lot switch I was very
bullish on the switch when it came out
but it blew away my expectations so like
it happens quite a bit and on the other
hand there's quite a bit of times where
a game comes out you're like wait a
minute that's all it's all I can't be
ready we're missing something so yeah it
happens all the time - the thing about
this industry and forecasts of this
industry is that you're gonna be wrong
and that whatever forecasts you have is
based on a set of assumptions that will
break the minute something launches like
we're not movies right we don't have
box-office to guide us we don't have
like audience feedback like when the
game launches it's basically we have an
idea what a game is but you never really
know until it's in the hands of players
and probably like some youtuber could
say something dumb and all of a sudden
your game Panks or on the other hand
some influencer could do something big
and also your game's huge and good point
happens all the time it's a it's a hard
business to try to track I don't know if
you're willing to like calm it on this
but what's your prediction is for C
themes so see this is I'm optimistic on
it but because it's part I think well I
think it's fantastic that is part of the
game past I think it's actually going to
improve the player account it's going to
lead to more sales because the people
playing it as part of game paths are
gonna tell their friends and bring them
in which i think is the whole point so
I've been very encouraged by what I've
been reading and hearing about beta
performance and and I think we're gonna
see more of this type of thing where it
there where like I said it's all about
engagement it's all about users sales
are secondary in a big case now and so
how do you get the most people playing
the game which the assumption
that you'll make more money either via
other people coming in to buy it or via
you know whatever in-game stuff you
might have in there but I'm gonna come
istic the game pass you know let's be
real here I don't even have to subscribe
to see if these
like they could go to a whole other game
and permit pretty much funding every
game and see in game pads game pastor
that's another question I want to get a
law sava
so I what you got yeah so to piggyback
off of what Matt said with with the
engagement right um it seems that
Microsoft is the only company who's
really outwardly talking about
engagement as as that is their main goal
they're not worried so much about like
the the sales numbers were not but they
want to make sure they keep you in that
ecosystem so do you think especially now
with Microsoft with this pricing model
that they have now with the announcement
state of decay and the $30 price point
and a $50 price point in addition to
game pass do you think this sort of this
sort of focus on engagement as something
that you know it's kind of something
like a term that the consumers are using
as well is that something that you think
that Nintendo and PlayStation need to
start doing in terms of instead of
focusing on actual sales it is it
something that they need to start
including and their vernacular uh so you
mentioned that Microsoft's are the folks
out there doing it publicly everyone's
doing it just not publicly so this is
the focus of everybody it is player
engagement so do they need to do
publicly now I mean I think a lot of
companies are talking to the investor
community and there and sales still
speaks to that crowd they'll get it
eventually that the engagement is what
drives the sales and they'll get there
but for now like most of us are talking
to the investment community and so
you'll you'll continue to focus on sales
but the actual how do we make games how
do we make systems the focus is on
engagement cool cool Lord King any
questions for the Lord of MPD
I know you can answer that questions
though it's like that that question is
not even valid you can't even answer the
question if our war agreement like so a
publisher or or a game maker can can
announce any number they want if they
own that number like if their number
they can say whatever they want they say
a number that's incorrect we have every
right to come out and say that they were
wrong double down looking have you ever
specifically encountered and come across
way it was incorrect numbers reported
and you guys had to send it back to us
but you don't have to call anybody out
but have you encountered no uh you know
so folks can get really creative this
and how they talk about the numbers and
they can use metrics I'm very silly
creative so but what we do is we go in
and like if there's a stay them out
there I will look at it and make sure
that it was accurate and even though it
might be worded in such a way to be
trying to sway one's opinion a certain
direction if it's actually correct then
it's actually correct and I haven't run
into a situation where someone is
intentionally mucked up a number or said
something wrong they can say things in
creative ways but seeing these numbers
and we seen these astronomical numbers
of these mythical playstation4 numbers
this these are come on Matt these are
unheard-of numbers and this young of a
generation of a system right
70 million so fast is astonishing um and
I truly believe that the engagement is
probably of the casual because the games
aren't selling to the number that you
would think that it was a 70 million
base you know I would think at least
let's say 2 percent of the of the
populace will purchase a one game and
translate into you know game sales but
you're not seeing like 2% purchasing
like one single game except for that
zero horizon dorm which they've said did
seven million so you said what are the
reasons why what did you want to show it
because you know we started this little
segment where we have two Lords of us
that we call the Illuminati Lords who
sometimes struggle to we know the
success of Sony has been extremely
extremely positive to generation but
also we know as far as the install base
what is it looking like what 7870
million right now maybe even 80 right so
the question comes out Pisco just to
help us understand like as far as the
prestige you know like pretend my
Corazon vanish hope seven point six
right you know their percentage in
comparison to the whole is that really
healthy is that not really reflective
when you know less than half owned a
specific title like what's that
definition of like a truly successful
title in that kind of an ecosystem in a
system selves that well that's a really
great question so really like like a 10%
10% attached right which is the horizon
zero dawn number kind of translates to
is nominal you don't see that kind of
attached outside of maybe like the Call
of Duty's or the or the rockstar games
of the world right so you're if you are
in mid-single digit attach rates you're
doing fantastic and this is why in the
cycle fairly early on like year one of
the cycle you'll see like you'll see
occasionally the like the hundred
percent Zelda attach rate or the 75
percent call duty to attach rate at
launch at 360 like they're very big rare
outliers but for the most part if you're
in year what are we in your seven six
six six or seven whatever when you're
this late in the cycle if you're getting
for 2% you're doing very well you have
such a wide array of content available
and people are using these things in
very different ways you have your your
your a person that goes out and they buy
Madden and call duty every year mm-hmm
and then you have your guy that just
plays FIFA and then you have like your
cat who's just using it as a blu-ray
player at this point the cycle is really
good okay cool thanks for that
clarification question we wouldn't know
now a question I have for you another
thing that we see out here in these
gaming streets is on game patch right
and I know lost all kind of touched on a
little bit but just kind of like I
wanted to get deeper like far like the
financial like revenue ramifications
from Microsoft because like there's this
perception right now that Microsoft is
giving away their triple-a first party
titles for free right so ultimately how
does that I know we talked about
engagement but like how does that
benefit them is there any type of a
short term loss initially or this is
just constant
you know revenue stream you know that
ultimately still is better than you know
by putting it in this game pass system
that they have right so you have you
also have EA access out there that kind
of led the way in this type of
initiative I don't know the specifics of
how the financials work on how they
allocate revenue across titles that
participate or how their advertising
cost rates like that but the idea is the
more you have people in the echo system
the more time they're spending the more
they'll spend either on other games are
on
downloadable content or micro
transactions so that's the bet right
mm-hm
I would not look at it as they're giving
things away for free cuz no one does
that but what we've seen and what the
data suggests is that titles that show
up in these subscription-based programs
whether it's PS Plus Xbox gold EA access
that when these games hit those services
sales of those exact games actually
increase above baseline 409 do following
that occurrence because what that does
is those
games back in back people are back
playing them they're showing up on
friends list activity feed people are
talking about the games again at some
point you'd have to imagine that the
number of games in a service like that
could dampen that impact or that effect
that halo effect not Master Chief halo
but halo as though but we haven't seen
it yet so I think that's the bet that is
like hey the more people are playing our
game the more people are gonna buy our
game even if the initial folks playing
it or getting a via subscription service
awesome let me go to keep them solid
what a quick question a small kids move
in reference to the same topic will
downloads from game pass count in MPD's
that was his question do you think oh
[Music]
that's a great question I don't believe
so we track subscription spending
outside we still track for subscription
spending as part of total overall
spending but we don't track it as part
of the individual game performance and
like I am a hardware bundle were you
like if you buy a ps4 and it has called
UT in it right that game sale isn't
counted it's counted as part of the
hardest part of the hardware oh ok
gotcha that's a great go quick thanks
for our question Lois mom says a very
good question very good question
Lord addict I cut you off I'm sorry my
god that was like another thing people
don't realize on the game pass this
stuff like halo wars 2 zone there and
they probably got 50 $60 worth the
expansions this people's gonna pick up
because of it game violence absolutely
hasn't been selling that much or
whatever like anything you get over your
baseline demands good right so you know
you you have game pastor you have some
other subscription service you have a
couple games out there that bring people
in the door but then they play other
things and overall you know the the
ocean Rises and the pie gets bigger and
I think that's the philosophy behind it
absolutely any other questions the Lords
have so with the pie back to like the
how Nintendo and Sony sort of react to
that in Nintendo
I think Matt made a comment a few days
back about how
physical sales are going to continue to
grow especially on the Nintendo side um
so it does Microsoft's kind of not
necessarily focus but that this with
their services being like digital based
do you see the other two kind of
following that route at some point
because I think a lot of people
including myself like I've gone
primarily digital everywhere right so
the fear is that like Microsoft sort of
has a roadmap for what they want to do
with with game pass in just the
Microsoft ecosystem in general and
PlayStation hasn't necessarily clarified
what they plan to do with that neither
has neither has Nintendo so it's like
you have kind of any comments on on what
they might be thinking and doing in the
future anything that might indicate that
they might be looking at that sort of
structure as well right so you have
short term and long term short term
maybe mid term so I'll call it the next
five years right I think what's happened
is each manufacturer has developed a
very specific approach through their
product and their customer base they're
differentiated so what Microsoft's doing
is different than what Sony's doing
which is different that went had what
Nintendo is doing I had that overall has
led to an increase in overall sales
because there you're no longer having
substitute products battle up against
each other right you back in the day if
you bought a ps2 or an Xbox it didn't
really matter which one you bought other
than the exclusive games that were
involved now like your the echo system
and how its structured is very different
so I think like Sony and Microsoft still
compete fairly directly but not as
directly as they used to and then
Nintendo's on a whole different like
things that happened to Nintendo have no
impact at all on ps4 Xone things happen
on ps4 Xone have no impact at all on
Nintendo so for the short term I think I
think everyone they've all found a sweet
spot with their customer I think they
hold on to that sweet spot but five plus
years out say we're 2022 2023 as long as
net neutrality doesn't get disintegrated
in any $200 for their internet
connection
any cops that can a world hut with with
hundred gigabyte games on you know
next-gen systems that's gonna have a big
impact on it what what net neutrality
looks like and then but ultimately I
think if if that works okay the
profitability on digital is so much
better that you're gonna see everyone
lean that way gotcha
now with that digital just a follow up
which your point on digital games now
with that Lou the rise of like digital
media kind of like accounting for more
of the percentages and sales and stuff
like has that been harder like to track
you know harder to implement I know
especially with Nintendo not really
reporting digital sales still to my
belief like how much you know do you
think that piece of the pie is missing
and do you think it will ever be kind of
fully implemented so we can get a true
you know idea of what the digital sales
health of is in gaming it's been
difficult no question so we have
something called the digital leader
panel we have a group of publishers that
do provide their digital data on Steam
Xbox and PSN it's basically all the big
ones with the exception of Bethesda
Nintendo decided work wow I didn't know
that I'm sorry Namco down the list
Capcom so we have a really good chunk of
digital data providers we can't speak
publicly on breakout so that kind of
thing but we do track them in the
overall spend but but we're missing DLC
we're missing MTX that we sell we have a
pilot program going on though so
hopefully within the next couple years
we get that going and we're still
missing the really big pie which is
those PC games the free-to-play PC
market so things like battlenet origin
you play League of Legends like we're
missing that spend too so it's a
challenge I think the the challenge is
that gaming has become so broad and
there's so many ways to engage with
gaming you know it's it's a tough
category to get you in all these
companies especially the big ones like
Vincent and all those are very private
with their data right so there's a long
way to go but I think we're doing a
better job than anybody else out there
and
in estimating this market and tracking
what we can track but yeah it's it's
it's not easy
I could imagine Oh
any other question before I have led
just to more from the fans and I just
want to make sure the Lord's question I
don't know if you could really comment
on this but what are the breakdowns from
digital cells of physical cells are they
actually a physical is still the primary
way people buy video games there
I think the misconception out there is
that the digital share rate is
consistent across titles and it
absolutely is not some titles will share
it a much higher digital level than
other titles I think what people get in
trouble with they go well X percent is
digital because one line in one report a
year ago said that and it's not the case
so it's very much a case-by-case basis
and it all depends on how the companies
are marketing and promoting their games
so the more game is promoted on those
storefronts with discounts and pre-order
bonuses and gold editions the higher
that digital share tends to be so cool
cool cool another point of contention
was a Noah a lot of the Xbox community
and fans you know you know sometimes the
inside joke is you know did they're
selling a lot of games were a lot of
controllers at accessories so my
question you is oh I know recently I
believe whose last NPD I think you had
made a tweet and it was just talking
about the health of of accessories and
how well it's doing I just want to know
if you can comment on that as far as I
mean obviously we know that there's
always a lot of new controllers or new
bundles that Microsoft puts out and just
people in general even the headset it
should I believe it was turtlebeach that
led and you know as mom's MPD you know
what's your standpoint on on the XS
reason you know reference to the
community saying you know why are they
doing that when maybe in reality is it's
actually successful for these companies
yeah accessories okay this is a really
good question too this is a fantastic
question it gets into some nothing's
variegated so accessories include we
report accessories includes things like
game cards headsets controllers cases
power supplies and things like toys to
life so what the accessories market is
actually healthier than we've been
reporting because the decline in toys to
life has been an offset on gains in
other areas so controllers have actually
done very well the last couple years for
both Sony and Microsoft and Nintendo and
the third-party guys so controllers have
done very well headsets and headphones
have done very well and switch things
like cases and power supplies have done
exceptionally well as as well but those
gains are being offset quite a bit by
this continued decline of the
interactive gaming toys so fortunately
that that decline is about done there's
not much more room again at this point
so I think you're going to start seeing
a reflection of even better accessory
reporting than we have been doing but
that's the question cool cool quick
question in reference to that too late
where does Lord Kings of me balls
falling this part of that interactive
gaming coy bucket it's it's the one that
does okay I think how I think they're
treating it more like a collectible now
than an actual toys to life
initiative and I think what you're gonna
see is more focused releases and a
higher priority on making sure the price
points can stay where they who saw that
Dark Souls one looking wasn't impressive
didn't think it did anything to help him
place that interest any any other
questions for the Lord's and I'll get my
last questions he'll add a quick
question or lordy real quick what what
happens if you can't be Dark Souls about
that extra a new your launch he said
about the amoeba what happens if you
can't complete Dark Souls without it you
don't gonna figure it out no I wasn't
picking it up anyway because it was
giving me no advantage I would like I
don't need the try-hard trophy you gotta
try on trophy there that's yours and
I'll take the casual trophy because this
actually gave me a little ghost Knight
that will run next
with stabbed people or gave me a spirit
actually one-hit-kill
yeah then we will both get the same
ending and you can have the mythical
pound-for-pound title that you hold
around so basically you're happy with
the that's right that's right that's
right you know we all used to look out
for it to Chico's so I come from an era
where we all went out and got a Chico
device game genie and stuff like that to
get god mode like that you come from I'm
gonna squeeze my knuckles until it works
in them no I came from this $60 brought
me game genie and we was handing our
codes and we were doing wild things even
before then I got in trouble so many
times I used to call us a good customer
service you send me they used to send me
maps and facts and stuff like that but I
need an amiibo one an amiibo
I want that amiibo to do special things
$60 or $15 or whatever I'm gonna pay
alright clarify real quick you are
playing Dark Souls no I'm not good
questions from the chat we have a
Enrique from the basically ok podcast a
guy he's had a quick question for Matt
he said do you think Microsoft and Sony
will release new hardware in 2020 yeah
cool piece ok so my forecast currently
has 2020 be in the year for a PS 5 and
whatever it is Microsoft doesn't axis
I don't think looking at the sales data
I don't see any reason to do it earlier
although I've been surprised in the past
we'll see how it goes but yeah 2020 is
my assumption ok cool cool cool
alright then uh my final question in
record
question segment we had the Lord of
every beyond infancy there was another
analyst of leaving your field um
she made some eye protection and he said
that uh he feels that Nintendo will
eventually surpass Microsoft's console
market share in 2018 and obviously I
don't want to say that comparison is a
hundred percent fair obviously you know
Nintendo has the switch the 3ds you know
a lot of limited time products like you
know the NES classic Super NES classic
well as Microsoft Jess has per saying at
the Xbox one but um we do know you know
the switch is what the switch is and as
far as 2018 coming in and you know what
do you feel in reference to these
analytics and these guys saying man 2018
that Nintendo could be could surpass
Microsoft in and out respect I don't
know there's so many there's so many
definitions of share it's kind of hard
to talk to you I don't know I haven't
even looked I don't generally look at
share not you I'm not trying to be
evasive of the question I don't I just
don't know if share matters like I know
it matters to people I know that it
matters to executives I know like people
are interested in the number but in
terms of like what is the ultimate
health of the industry how are things
selling what's gonna move what's not
gonna move share is the result of all
those things and not a driver of those
things if you know what I mean yeah I
know it sounds like I'm trying to evade
the question I'm I'm not I just I have
no idea where the share structure is
right now or even like to kind of share
they were talking about no fair enough
except we even appreciate you even going
into that and Antonette much appreciated
in regards to that question did they
specifically say just Nintendo as a
whole I know you mentioned other
products what did they say switch
specifically no they're saying you know
they said Nintendo as a whole they
saying they saying Nintendo will surpass
Microsoft as a whole so that that that's
where they going out you know in
apparently this guy market he predicted
they should shoulder Marcus off out of
the number two position this year you
know I'm saying so again but I
understand the risk that was point in
reference to you know
the terminology and sharing what really
you know saying like that means I got a
big so I can understand I always come
from in that respect I think switch wins
out in sales this year I would say no
and say there's an overall sales of
consoles I think they probably sell the
most consoles this year where that puts
them you know in the overall you know
picture I have no idea but yeah I think
I mean they're really I think this year
they gonna they're gonna run slip shot
this sorry yeah console or two in the
driver of a physical software digital
software not so much but yeah no worries
cool so appreciate all those answering
those questions for us a lot of gamers
you know always everyone that they we
always have these discussions these
debates and it's always good to get some
clarity so appreciate with that now we
got some we were getting these topics
and it's a couple of topics but actually
has some hot off the presses
at the roundtable raven was set from the
other lords so it looks like um just
actually yesterday a couple few days ago
one of our Bioware's most prominent
writers drew a can't pronounce this
guy's knee a mistake RP Sheehan um he
was actually the leader writer of Mass
Effect 2 so has just been reported that
um he's left arm Bioware and he was the
one writing the actual he left the
studio don't leave writer from Anthem
so looks like Casey yeah the reason why
you know I bring this King because again
just want you know clarify you know
Casey Hudson you know actually the GM
you know huge fan of Casey Hudson
you know from Mass Effect 1 he actually
came out in a statement and respond to a
twitter friend he basically just said
look that a corporation had at have
finished his work and he said his work
was already completed and then he left
you know and then they did speak to you
know corporation again apparently it's
not the first time he's left before like
he's he was probably his best known for
his being the lead writer from Mass
Effect 1 & 2
and then between the periods of Mass
Effect 2 and 3 then he left me kind of
wanting to do novels in his own kind of
graphic novel kind of thing but yeah he
put it on his personal site left again
so I want to bring this to the lawyers
like what do we feel about this is this
Shades of Destiny - are we over blowin
this where this is hot off the presses
The Raven just came through and drop the
note off ow
what the Lord's fit is very valid it
makes you get queasy in the stomach
especially we keep associating the
anthem with destiny so now it's probably
living up to the whole destiny uh Monica
that has set forth because what did we
lose did we lose the writers before
destiny and it had to do some real
condensed version and they said that we
were gonna get so much more content this
time and so much story I'm just like
that I hope is I hope you know he did
finish his job and he didn't rage quit I
hope um but you know we can only time
will tell
Lord addict I'm curious about your
perspective as destiny guys initially
you know what do you feel about this
when you heard this news mm-hmm I guess
it's good on if you know if it went
exactly the way they said he finished
his project but you better be hoping
that it didn't go that way you're right
you're absolutely right with this thing
the density - is it right there they
meet a few winds were you interested in
any capacity oh absolutely uh you know
video game projects these days are
hundreds of people who are dedicated to
the project one person coming or going
while having an impact at the leadership
level doesn't necessarily mean a game
turns out that are aware so I I have no
idea like there's so many people
involved and so many people have their
passion of the game that you know these
things these things happen I don't know
no I'm sure they happen a lot more than
like yeah game makers don't have a name
like that you know on this hot off the
presses yeah I mean I'm kind of with
matalas I don't know what to think about
it I think the fact that they got out in
front of it means that they know the
type of impact that something like this
can have on the community and
speculation so I it's gonna be a matter
of this seeing what else happens around
the game if we get more delays if we
keep going um you know taxes III es or
whatnot without seeing a substantial
chunk of this game and seeing what the
game is then maybe we worry about what's
happening with it as of right now it's
one person is significant because he
sort of drives a narrative of what you
know the story so um so it's big but at
the same time like I'm not gonna yeah
I'm just gonna wait and see and honestly
more bad stuff starts to happen around
it and then maybe you worry right well I
know I mean I'll finish it off I know
well it wasn't it Jason sorry I put
something out recently and he was just
basically going off onto you know the
constraints that they were under and
obviously we know that as far away as a
studio but we know that uh you know Mass
Effect Andromeda didn't really hit as it
should and there's some changes there so
we do know regardless to the speculation
we do know that there's a lot of
pressure on this town this is a very
highly anticipated title they have a lot
of stock in this title like Matt you
know Laura Stella said you know who
knows I mean this could be something
that he could have been done already you
know and then he's just moving on but
again you know - Lord Kings point you
know as des depends we've heard kind of
like this kind of rhetoric before that
said that this is the case with but you
know it just it just makes you raise
your eyebrow you just hope everything's
okay you hope the game comes out you
know there's a lot riding behind it
we'll just let's see what happens man
you know whenever I hear lead riders
before I gave release it just robot you
have dusty stuff that was quite
interesting you know when just came out
but we move into these topics Lord saw
Nintendo had a direct this week that's
good over yes they did they dropped it
on everybody's noses I'm
it was just one of those things with no
but there was no speculation about this
one so it was kind of a surprise and
yeah I mean listen if you've if you've
been someone who's been critical of
Nintendo for porting everything under
the Sun to the switch this is probably
not the direct for you that never isn't
that narrative hasn't changed that much
in terms of me though I'm happy so let's
I mean let's start off with the 3ds
stuff Studios very quickly last we the
tail of the the 3ds just can't you can't
deny it
like sails tails this game it's so
successful I can't be mad at them for
continuing to release games for it at
the same time you see that you know that
there segment is getting smaller and
smaller so then it is getting near the
end of his life site how close that is
will you know we don't know but I
mentioned it specifically because their
games coming to the 3ds now that I still
wish they were coming to the switch as
well so you have a compilation of war
games and I think some new stuff in
there as well that's coming to 3ds so
that's something I think that would do
extremely well on the switch and I wish
it was coming here
um a game called dillion's dead heat
breakers which is sort of like strategy
mix with action it was announced in the
papers good yeah it was initially
announced for Japan and we're getting it
now on the 3ds and then you're getting
marry a luigi bowser's Inside Story it's
coming back and I guess a this this time
it has Bowser jr. isn't as well so
another game that I think would love to
come to the switch and then the last two
things were Detective Pikachu's finally
coming to the west and so with that
we're gonna we're gonna get old man
Pikachu weird that you so weird but it's
coming with with new amiibo of course
you know they can't
the ears perked up when I said amiibo
he's a big and he's a big and he's a
nice size amiibo - he's a big and and
then finally we're getting Luigi's
Mansion a remake from GameCube game now
why are we not getting this on switch
you're right cousin right I think
they're at the point though they could
just take it just release them for both
day and date and you'd be fine
all I know is PlayStation and Xbox
better hope they never get rid of that
because that's where you think their
games are going on this list we know we
know the indie help is really doing well
you know yeah when they put they put
these titles out and switch in
comparison to magic you know next
Pokemon announced that it wasn't coming
on the 3ds and it was only on the switch
you're gonna force a lot of 3ds owners
to go out and buy a switch torches and
that game will be announced for the 3ds
they have is way more 3ds as out there
than switches torches come out yeah let
me let me ask more piscatella there's
almond reference to that being it I'm
seeing this in the chat now that what
you're talking about it you know the
health of the 3ds because it still I
guess doing so well you know is that
proud of a factor as to why the antennas
like you know we're not gonna completely
abandon it still you know a lot of
revenue there you know most most people
most gamers want them like myself
selfishly I'm a switch owner so I do
want them to move on but from a business
standpoint I do understand if it's
really doing well it's kind of hard to
just abandon it like what's your thought
process on that yeah so sales the last
few years been very consistent generally
you see this late in the cycle you know
sales really kind of tail off down to
nothing but thanks to their release
schedule and just how basically that and
because they've started to emphasize the
2d s instead of the 3ds and lower the
price point like sales been very
consistent it's almost weird how like
basically
every year it's the same number as long
as people are engaging and so and what
they're kind of do is right now they're
trying to provide mom something the hand
of the kid that's not the cellphone like
so at $79 three DS for a $9 radius R 2 D
s house Pokemon on it and a couple other
games fantastic all you needs like the
target the target market is very
different target markets definitely kids
presence which is definitely adults
prospective you want everything on
switch but there are pretty good reasons
they keep these things going and I
forgot who said it but someone just said
a minute ago yeah they can bring it out
to switch later yeah brothers for the
3ds and they we know and it's sold I
mean you got a look at it man that
market is not a market that you
abandoned you know my son plays this to
BDS really hard he just went to the
store the game stopped the birthday
switch and he got all his little arm you
know 3ds games so he really plays it you
know and he does every console so really
favors actually okay you're making a
good point because yeah okay good luck
I'll let you finish I'm okay with the
3ds being around but I feel like there
you know if it wasn't for the switch
being so popular and it wasn't it for
the switch you know having that
portability like I feel like they'd be
making the same mistakes because it does
look like sometimes they you know a lot
of the times I favor the 3d like who
would not want a Luigi's Mansion remake
why isn't that on the switch that makes
no sense
same thing with Metroid when my trade
came out and like like matt said like
the demographic for the 3d s at this
point should be fairly younger so why
not give the more adult game Metroid to
the people on switch No yeah but to put
your Kings point which is kind of
doubling down on what in conjunction of
what Laura saying is that um it's like
Lord Kings like look the switches his
adult system
he's not giving it to his you know
saying he's not giving it to given him a
3d s so basically it falls in line what
I'm saying is that you know that's how
they're viewing it and that market is
still strong it's like you know you you
will damage the hot new Ferrari you get
this is always going to be children you
know as long as they are children
Nintendo will thrive like no other and
that portability he goes to the doctor's
office and you give him the 2d s and he
playing it I'm sorry they can't get rid
of that thing it is winning right now
like he said it's consistent every year
because it's children being born every
year absolutely absolutely yeah what
else did a Nintendo have for us so now
we jump into the switch stuff um and
yeah we were seeing a lot of ports but
the stuff that we say that we wanted to
see a captain toad treasure tracker is
finally coming coming to both 3ds and
the switch after being on the Wii U so
that's fantastic cuz I never played it
on me I'd love to have it on the switch
in terms of more ports there they gave a
date for Hyrule warriors definitive
edition again dynasty warriors isn't my
thing first day but hey it's good to see
it on a switch um in terms of
third-party stuff we have South Park the
fractured but whole finally coming we
talked about this last night how it was
I hope they announced like a package
deal with that and the stick of truth
because it only makes sense that they
package both games I've been told that
they're both coming out yeah it makes
sense would that's you get y'all we
can't we can't that's a huge hit for
them I've know I'm gonna have to be real
why I've definitely been on the the
Nutri side of Nintendo where they could
go or they could come it doesn't really
matter and that director like I was okay
I can okay alright I was like wow really
we have a surprise because that means a
lot of ports that have the biggest issue
is are they committing to third party
and if they're having South Park yeah
their committee okay that's good that's
good to see his third party committing
to them that's that's the whole thing is
you know I always felt that it was a
Nintendo you know telling people no it
was the other people telling Nintendo no
with the Wii U and right now they're
riding such a high that these guys got
to get on a lay down it's just very
simple the numbers are showing that
they're selling and why not have your
game there so it can sell just do at a
very decent port don't do WWE oh yeah oh
and we have like we have little
nightmares coming as well a game that
came out on ps4 initially and PC I think
and then Xbox and now it's coming to
switch we have the Travis strikes again
on they showed a little more footage of
that which is uh anybody who's a fan of
No More Heroes should be interested in
this no weirdness that is Travis
touchdown and then you know I guess they
gave more info on Kirby Star allies
which I downloaded the demo Kirby star
allies it's so beautiful and it's such a
cute and endearing game but it but it's
just so Kirby and so easy like it's just
one of those things I'll get it when
it's on sale just to have it on my
console but it is it is a very pretty
game mmm and definitely speaks to that
younger demographic that I think is just
gonna eat it up yeah um so besides that
oh we have undertale coming as well
undertale finally going to know yeah
that's a big one when it was huge on PC
a lot of people we even had it up as a
game of the year then they the your they
launched so it's it's good to get that
game on there um and then we have then
we have a combi HD HD remake with motion
controls I believe too yeah you have
motion controls you can play the number
of different ways and you're getting an
HD version I was kind of worried that
you'd get maybe if it was coming we were
gonna get the older version without like
the updated graphics and whatnot so it's
good to see that it's coming a lot of
people a lot of people Okami
is just as good as some of the best
Zelda games stole Tommy's a classic to
see it on the switches fan
tastic and I'm gonna have to penalize
you for that statement what did you just
say a lot of people a lot of people
think not although the games sums oh the
game commies up there with it I didn't
say for myself don't the wrath of a
teeth um
fired a button to push and you just
jumped out oh let me see on that okay we
have crashed the bandicoot is coming to
them with never saw something there's
some people I mean again it's to me
Activision is gonna do what they're
gonna do and they saw the success they
had with it on the PlayStation obviously
the platform that introduced the world
to crash so um but I guess it only makes
sense that it comes to other consoles
Activision owns the property now they
saw the success it had on the ps4 they
want to see that continue hopefully if
it of the sales are right on Xbox and
the switch we're gonna see a new crash I
[Laughter]
mean it's good to me it crash the best
chance of coming back blooming in a new
iteration so it's fantastic to see
everyone it's too long is to drawn-out
but here is the Cliff Notes version Matt
I am so happy that a property that was
supposedly
schools really wasn't because it was on
an Xbox system before is now being able
to be enjoyed by everyone I love that
part that's all do you like these games
I don't know man exclusivity I get the
business pays for it yeah but but shoot
man like these these are fun games that
people should just have fun playing so
the business kind of gets in the way of
that sometimes the final big three
announcements
um so splatoon 2 is getting a dlc add-on
with the octo links and it's a
single-player like robust add-on um it's
for 2 - man I guess it's it's big here
it is huge in Japan huge in Japan so the
fact that um they're continuing to add
to this game shows the confidence they
have in its property and the
single-player stuff I thought was cool I
in person - I liked it I could have done
with more platforming elements like I
think they needed to incorporate it more
to make it feel more like a platformer
with you know like if you look like
Mario Sunshine or something like that
use that as sort of like a baseline for
how to handle like the water physics and
stuff like that and the ink physics um
so that's very cool to see um Mario
Tennis they broke down the gameplay of
Mario Tennis they didn't go too much
into um like the story mode in the
campaign what not but they broke down
the gameplay and they added so many
different things in terms of like trick
shots and like countering trick shots
like they really broke down and they got
in depth they got in depth with it and
it again they made the game a lot more
robust and then they also allow you to
play it in a less rkd way with like
regular rules no crazy trick shots so
I'm kind of excited for marrow tennis I
want to see what the story mode does and
they kind of turn things around on that
um and then the big one both the big one
Oh everybody knew what it was coming but
it didn't keep people from looting their
minds when they saw
smash brothers was announced for the
switch boom with the octolings in tow so
they're gonna be in the switch version
um yeah people lost their minds
everybody knew it was coming was just a
matter of time they were not not going
to release Smash Brothers on the switch
um but I think the speculation now is
what is it it is it something brand new
or is it just a souped up Wii U version
just that there's a lot of speculation
I'm going on in reference to that and I
know people saw that they saw a breath
of the wild link in the back and there's
a lot of speculation going on but let's
bring let's bring it to the table into
law Chris could tell um what did you
feel overall about the Nintendo Direct
did it excite you anything specifically
was your thought process on it yeah so
like okay let's talk about smash for a
second because I'm a little confused
I'm so confused so so smash hat or the
switch has the online service coming
later this year right yes they need
something to put with that product no we
had offering and of course it was going
to be smash the most the most like the
most of course announcement of the whole
direct it just seemed the most obvious
thing going into it this would be the
the takeaway and yet I all I see the
videos of grown-ass man like that ya
know do it was he's correct I mean I was
retweeting the day it was announced I
mean people were it's not I had huge a
feeling that was gonna happen like
people in the Nintendo New York store
and I guess they were late love and they
are great people were passing
like of course they're gonna do that
with the switch online offering I think
it's a fantastic game to come day one
with the online offering so we'll see
how that says I wanted to touch on one
other point that well two points really
that were made in the conversation one
on the Okami or alchemy Okami HD like so
I bought that game on I bought that game
on ps2 I bought it on 360 I think I've
bought it on PC I'm gonna buy it again
for switch I might actually play it this
time you'll actually be able to do like
the mechanics of the lines circles
without being frustrated to hell and
back so I'm looking forward to that he's
a mechanic actually workers yeah nothing
terrible I'm looking forward to that but
on the on the indie development see
we're talking a little bit about it
earlier about how like games are doing
best on switch Li's any developers we're
seeing a lot of these games come to the
platform I think we're gonna see so many
of them that it's going to be a little
bit problematic of for discovery I think
it's gonna be like just a whole wave of
these games like we're now we're getting
like 10 a week by the end of this year
we're probably in 15-20 a week and a lot
of them being good mm-hmm if you look at
the GDC the Game Developers Conference
which is coming up here in two weeks yes
they do a state of the industry survey
every year and they publish it you can
go check it out online it's fully free
but it's it's a number of developers
will respond about what they see is the
big trends of gaming and the responses
of this year's survey are all about
Switch how excited the indie development
scene is for switch not optimistic they
are on the platform and so I think
you're gonna see just a I think this is
like what we're seeing right now like
these directs they're they're pretty
fantastic announcement packages but I
think as the year goes on we're just
going to see so much come to the switch
which is a good thing which is a good a
great thing but it's also a bit of a
challenge mmm
now you say like a challenge in what way
like I kinda like from oversaturation or
yeah yeah when you have so many games
coming every week it's hard to figure
out what's good and what's not and let's
be honest the eShop is not built for
discoverability correct absolutely
correct I have to give you that they
have to figure out a way to tackle that
you're gonna say something sovereign in
reference to no no he's right I mean
it's just not
this point you would think that with the
when the online service comes comes on
they've had some sort of overhaul to
that because he's like Matt says like I
know king for a long time was saying
like you know there's a lot of
shovelware on there into smaller games
it's smaller games as you don't you
don't know about them but a lot of them
that's I mean that's why we just you
know myself because Neto kept just going
back to it because it's like yeah but
when you're releasing 10 games a week
and six or seven of them are good mm-hmm
I mean that's unprecedented you don't
find that anywhere seven of them are
good Yorick waiting York waiting a $4.99
price point bad don't put me in that
group I mean there's so many of them
there were a lot of them why do you
think I'm just gonna go play self-aware
for the sake of place level where like I
have all the games to play so I'm gonna
Swit it I'm looking at these games what
I'm looking at are the games that have
primarily been on PC that are coming
over they were popular on PC right and
games that have come over to console as
well therefore you know again I'm
playing mostly triple-a stuff of my
consoles very I'm not gonna take the
time out to play an indie game so much
on my comms the same way yeah the
Glovers indie game on the goal and it's
what I think that's play anything that
has a trial available that I can get my
little fingers on the type and once you
got a trial out and then I say to myself
like nine parchments I really wanted to
check it out and then I played it and I
said wow I'm a purchase this put a trial
out let the King touch and if the King
likes the King buys some paint from
software and put a trial for Dark Souls
you could do that trihard stuff I told
you all right you know what petition
them get an amiibo to helps me
what kind of me but do we need to I
wanna meet Bo there push you like a
ghost dog or something
me Bo that gives them like magic darts
where it kills everything that's right I
want Vantage no I mean I mean III get
what Matt saying like you get to a point
where there's so much good stuff and
there's no way to filter that out it's
tough it's tough and it anything
anything on the UI front that's very
complicated he's gonna make that switch
run kind of thing it's gonna start
chugging a little bit so it's something
to consider how they handle all that
stuff moving forward yeah he shops can
feel yeah they have so right now it the
system's one year old there are 48 48 on
my account 48 games rated 80 or higher
on the system that's never happened
before and as we get more and more games
coming to switch it's going to become a
bigger problem finding these great games
I don't know interested to see how this
all works a lot of people don't believe
how many have need according to open
critic according to open critic there
are 48 games on switch ready 280 or move
on I did have a little knack to the pool
how dare you dreamcast guy to put mario
odyssey over the legend of zelda on your
top-10 switch games really we got to
bring dreamcast guy back on we'll have
to clarify that uh you know he must have
been under duress when he said that
someone secretly had a gun to him both
the good guys only guy only on the
direct and we move on to our final topic
and that is the insert at xbox went down
the big show
the next box has been teasing
you know they came out on stage this
Saturday they had a lot to discuss it
was pretty long actually it's almost two
hours and it looks like the act the Xbox
engineering team Larry her Major Nelson
with those white gloves
Kasich bigs but it looks like the first
things big is a good announce was all
from AMD they talked about the AMD
Radeon the freesync display technology
so they're gonna be enabling that to
work with the Xbox one you know they
talked about a lot of the UI updates
they had a shared a Twitter you know
stuff the people in the Alpha ring like
myself and these people will be getting
I can actually can do it now but the
future our update will definitely go out
to the rest of the community so you can
do it straight from screenshot to your
Twitter no extra website in the middle
as a middleman you know they also talked
about the Auto low latency mode which I
thought was pretty cool like almost like
with Samsung TVs they have a game mode
so it's gonna recognize the games being
played that way automatically switch
your TV to a low latency mode this is
great for FPS first person shooters
except like that would even kind of have
an advantage and also when you're doing
you know go on switch in fact back
between movie streaming and so on and so
forth
browser edge browser got an update share
controller mixer was announced and then
they definitely double down on see if
thieves we know that's a game pass game
that's coming so they gave us a lot of
background information on that they deep
dive into that and as well it was like
kind of music segment which is pretty
interesting I had a couple little quests
and bundles that they talked about
things like that so on and of course you
know game pastor the last time we they
initiate is talked about the city
skylines and how that's gonna be
entering game pass so I just want to get
thoughts from the round table and was
get more piscatella on this and if you
got a chance to catch the inside of Xbox
and if he did you know what was his
thoughts and impressions so not related
it wasn't the fall of the show I was on
the road
he's always tired but he works a lot
been really per six that out for you
percent not for me did you at least
catch the the white gloves did you catch
the white gloves on Twitter later and
the panic about dropping the box you
know like so you gotta give him credit
for one thing like they are really into
hardware and making things pretty and
shine leggy like they make they make
really nice-looking hardware and that's
always fun to watch yeah she so you cut
the golden banana and the golden Xbox 1x
in any first of all who did get a chance
to watch this whole thing yet anybody
else finish it you know at least catch
most of it okay I thought that they need
to adopt a more Nintendo Direct type of
way of doing things they just seem like
the not so hip older uncle that tries to
be hip and it's like hey what you guys
are doing it's lit outside no don't say
that
oh that's how it comes across to me yes
it's cringe-worthy but I've noticed now
because I'm looking at the Xbox
Dashboard and they broke it down like I
said into snippets of five minutes what
I said is what they should've did was do
the show as a whole and release it at 20
minute segments on a Friday if you
choose every week or you know break it
down even further that it's like five
minutes every day of the weekend Friday
Saturday Sunday and has something to
look forward to the way that people are
consuming things they want to quick they
want to fast they just want the
information I think the Nintendo directs
are done perfectly that they control the
narrative to get out of the way of the
videogames they put the videogames front
and center let you see what you want to
see I don't care for the banter back and
forth I don't care for the
to action between the there was like a
game show like contestants it just it
brought me the completely the wrong way
and they have been missing the mark on
that so much and presentation Sony his
King and ten to a second and following
by a third is Microsoft always mmm fair
enough fair enough
Lord adequate curious uh we watched a
bit of it together
you watch buddy so um you know what what
did you feel what's your whole thing do
you think it was like a as far as the
format or what I need to change why I
don't know why people expected it to be
easier caliber like this is monthly this
isn't like one thing they did this is
actually like more consistent than
directs are it's gonna be every month
regardless sometimes you go like a
couple months about directs mm-hmm this
is the fact thing is the fact that you
love and like it's a monthly thing well
it's not that it's just
I had my expectations to how it was got
you put into place it's like they expect
first off of any kind of big
announcements that's always III mmm-hmm
that's when the most eyes are on that
they're not gonna show like the next
fable you know I feel like this is
mainly a platform that you know places
like first at IGN when they have a state
of the decay that you might see less and
less of that and more and more on this
got you okay let me ask you this
question what I could you yes she got my
mind racing so do you think they're
gonna use this more in conjunction you
know to see a thief they really double
down and we do know that's coming very
shortly right and it's in the game but
do you think they also gonna use this as
a platform springboard like the gamepad
stuff as well and really get more on to
death like what's gonna happen next
month mmm satisfied yeah you know
obviously there was a lot of corny
moments like a lot like a lot of law
look like every I feel like I was saying
that was corny more than I was actually
watching this yes cuz I agree but it was
good for what it is like people want
what they want and they wanted
exactly how they want it like we've got
what we wanted you didn't get it exactly
how you wanted like you can't have both
sometimes the finance is coming at you
he said you're damaged controlling two
hours long he's coming for you hard to
chat bro like he's not playing no games
to chew on point at Xbox you want the
r-rated version loads up what do you
know King said and what haddock said
because the King I do I do agree that
they're just bad at mess at how they
message things and like they they're bad
just being quick concise get to the
point focus on what everybody wants to
see which is the game's mom or the
announcement like quickly focused on the
announcement the you know the the banter
between like hosts and stuff like that
it's just it's I don't I don't care for
I just want to see the games like with
Nintendo directs they control the
message and they still manage to give
you some of that Nintendo weirdness and
quirkiness you know they still give you
that so it's it's something that they
just need to work on in that with that
all the only one that feels like
Nintendo is gonna do that little snap
their finger thing every talking about
that last night how that gives you the
cue there's something newts coming on
the screen if they're talking about
something that you don't care for you
know when he snaps his fingers there's
something mm-hmm it just it's been there
from the beginning is perfect not sure
what but two addicts point yeah I do
think like it's funny it gives it the
opportunity to evolve right yes I don't
necessarily see this being the format
for next but once think I think done the
content is gonna is gonna kind of
dictate how they handle it on a
month-to-month basis I don't necessarily
see it being this this you know this
stagnant thing every month that it's
gonna be the same format and whatnot and
then from the amount the stuff that they
announced themselves you know me I'm a
tech head so like for me that the
variable refresh rate stuff is that was
what got me game or 45
like get over that stuff yeah the game
mode stuff not so much for me I only
play in low latency mode any time like
in a competitive shooter or something
like that beyond that I don't turn it on
I think it affects because it affects
really Oh quality yes the quality of
burst Li a little bit so I'd rather not
but if you're putting something
competitive yeah you give yourself the
best advantage you possibly can but the
variable frustrates stuff is huge
because not everybody plays on on
monitors and not everybody has a free
six monitor but this over the past year
I think it started they start to be TVs
that are implementing it more and more
and I think as as this stuff becomes
more ubiquitous and consoles you know
Xbox doing it now
maybe PlayStation does it in the future
I think we'll start seeing more TVs that
support it so it's good I think it's a
huge thing jump in real quick
I mean yes I mean I watched it without
wood addict Tom yeah it was a little too
long and sleep-inducing assertive but
Brett you might do okay but you can't
tell me that you had zero expectations
for this and then complain when it one
didn't go to your expectations that does
that's literally contradicting what you
just said you can't have zero
expectations if you like they didn't
have they I didn't really think they're
gonna show anything and then well how
long was uh was your guys's podcast
yesterday oh we did loads of arcade
whole time complaining about it and then
expect me to believe you've really had
zero expectations last night they had a
good show and I'm also shout to Lord Sam
Tolbert our Lord editor I came in you
know I came in low expectations I knew
at this point in the stage where
Microsoft is from me I'm just happy that
they're doing something like this this
is something that
soft really hasn't done this Jen so far
you know you know Sony's been the king
of that with the PS X's and all these
other low shows and stuff like that
Nintendo's been pumping it out with the
directs to direct minis so just for
Microsoft to say look we're gonna throw
ourselves and I had this is something
the fans won because let's be honest the
fans get tired of just waiting for III
and hopefully maybe they say something
in games car so as a monthly thing I
think that's pretty cool you know was it
a restructure it yeah they got a
restructure it's the first one it was it
way too long yes was it you know your
weird uncle awkward in some parts though
I say quoted major Nelson's gloves more
than anything yeah that's a good guy
like he was Vanna White out there with
this white I'm just like well yeah look
man this is ridiculous and one thing I
do have an issue what they did is like I
thought they were gonna show us new
stuff on see if these they literally
showed us everything we've already know
like it was nothing new that does kind
of make me a little bit aggravated
because it's like you know I understand
they're trying to say stuff like the
Kraken for launch there's a lot of
people that's completely down the middle
with this game so they want to do
something to win them over and what they
showed yesterday just re showing
everything they've showed is not the way
to do it
got you so again you know this is
something that you know they can learn
as far as presentation just like Lord
King said you know Sony I feel is king
with knowing how to present how to get
that stuff i we reiterated you know
again last night on Lords of the arcade
with Enrique and um you know I said I'm
just glad the hats in the ring I'm glad
it's monthly though you know I'm to me
honest state of decay is more my game so
that's the inside Xbox that's gonna
happen with inside Xbox it's gonna show
the majority of those they might recap
it recap what they do what I can but I
would expect state of decay to in some
form at the next inside Xbox especially
when this is a platform that they can
use to promote those game pass exclusive
games it's gonna be dropping because the
key did a service like this if it's
gonna adopt like this Netflix tile
service the key is gonna be content you
have to keep producing exclusive content
and make people want to stay subscribe
and stay engaged with said service so
I mean he's just my opinion what do you
feel Malthus is in reference to you know
they would gain pass in promotion like
what do you feel about that they they're
gonna have to keep bringing new content
and and cycling stuff out and keeping
people in service yeah I mean how many
subscription service really works when
it's not tied to paying for multiplayer
gameplay you're bringing it up Matt like
why like they're gonna use this service
and they're gonna do every month don't
say we're gonna announce one game coming
the game past next month we'll save the
rest for later why probably announce
them all on that platform if you want
that to actually do something it's gonna
be interesting you know I mean we'll see
this thing hopefully may evolve you know
this may not be the set format they may
be still finding their way but uh you
know that's what I had on anything of
the Lord you know had anything else
we'll wrap this thing up um yes so it
looks like we had a got the new i/o
people which we based on said show so
with the recent return of microsoft's in
the inside xbox show how satisfied are
we with the format slash direction of
the show the choices are a relaxed it
was just the debut show is perfectly
fine as it is be show it's way too long
needs to mimic condensed in tendo direct
format see presentation needs to improve
and mimic sony or d i don't care as long
as i get major they'll sit at those
white gloves paralyzed that your life
choices almost not that ridiculous i had
a loved it like spreading like a plague
that is please back to vote it hit the
IOP Twitter polls heart wouldn't go up
Lord that piscatella of the NPD group
much appreciated for stopping by in the
realm of the Lord's dropping knowledge
educate
nice educate in the chat absolute
pleasure to have you on the show that
where can the fine people find you or
what else do you have going on oh man
well thank you very much nearby it's
been awesome great spending part of
Sunday with you
I don't know I'm on Twitter at Matt
piscatella with one tea because my mom
was on drugs in the nice Pam definitely
give us the links to those part those
are posts and I'll put them up and also
will we be getting any of those your
monthly NPD videos I really really look
forward to those like all those coming
back yes oh I miss January things happen
so for February I'll be in a hotel room
for four days with not much else to do
at night so yeah I'm guessing February
it's gonna come back it should be what
right around I don't know the 20th or
whatever day that is yes yes nice 21st
xx xx xx all right so we're gonna look
out for it on the 20th now real quick
question in reference to generally it's
like the after the 15th of the month is
when generally those numbers you're
allowed to kind of talk about them put
them out for the previous month
yeah it's I it works out the retail
calendar and it's all confusing
generally the second or third Tuesday of
the month is when these things will come
out but it's it's weird
it depends at the mercy of those of does
very much yeah pretty much it's all
retail calendar base but I generally
posted on Twitter about when it's coming
out absolutely also please support like
I said you can catch him as well
she's on the SDG see podcast great
groups guys Lord negative he's been on
the show multiple times
also you can catch them sometimes on the
basement radio arcade podcast also
dropping knowledge over there who is in
the chat you know so really appreciate
that so we're gonna get our outros going
on my co-host with the cold most Lord
addict what do you have cooking up and
when can the fine people find you I
guess he
we found the toothpick of death was this
my outro yes out Joe Tampa I appreciate
everyone for coming by I definitely
appreciate Matt for coming by
you know it's like I said at the
beginning of the podcast I wanted to
actually sit down I have a conversation
with you so I made myself get up with a
wisdom tooth impacted appreciate it I
definitely follow you on twitter and uh
thanks for all the hard work you do in
the industry thank you right on
absolutely and definitely Lord in the
ramp Lord sovereign it's going on with
you in a what can the five people that
much thanks to Matt for coming to we
realized how hectic your schedule is
like it's kind of nuts it and we
appreciate so much that you take time on
your schedule to come in and talk to us
because I know you know it has to be
kind of crazy like you're being sort of
like the fuel for the fanboy warhorses
it's always great to have you on and for
you to kind of set people right and give
your perspectives on what's going on in
this industry that we all love so really
appreciate your time man all right on
anytime that was fun
absolutely Lord King where can you find
people kind of that we got we got the
clarification that with the budget I
love that segment that was awesome look
you know it looks like he's muted remain
stuffed away a little bit hopefully we
get him that well sorry
first of all first and foremost I would
like to say thanks Matt for showing up
great show um I know it's no big rate
show which he was on a lot of viewers
are tuned in to listen to what you had
to say and to get a better understanding
of how they actually work how the
numbers actually work and you were very
articulate and clear and getting it
across you actually asked to answer the
question that I didn't think that she
was gonna even approach very happy in
that um like I said I'm so happy that
you showed up
define people can find
on Twitter Instagram no you know just
look for me on Twitter and Xbox and
Playstation your PlayStation game yes
tell them everyone your PlayStation game
attack they love oh and it says real
Matt is xbox360 lover or one and the
fact that Sony doesn't allow you to
change the name it's mine forever gaming
realness has been spread in the realm
once again much appreciated for Laura
piscatella coming out taking time out of
his extremely busy schedule really
appreciate what he does but for gamers
he's very personable you know definitely
if you have any questions tweet him he's
very active on Twitter and it's always
good to see the trends in the industry
and just to learn where things are going
and again really can't thank you enough
for coming by the Iowa podcast and
dealing with our foolishness in the
realm of the Lord's but oh yeah man
we're gonna do I'll just real quick
please hit like I said thank everyone
for hit and like and subscribe chat was
absolutely live today thank you so much
for all the support in our spell in the
inner circle Network media outlets tech
podcast was last night they had a great
show the multi-verse
is up tomorrow also you can catch us on
iTunes and SoundCloud the links are
gonna be in the description I'm gonna
also have a Matt piscatella info in
there as well as well as YouTube channel
because I love those videos when he puts
them out but also yeah thank you for
also continue to support the flashpoint
series that I knew what he bought is
number seven is up it was a fun show we
had a lot of stuff going on there and we
got some more stuff cooking up you know
the Lord's will be at PAX you know
hopefully e3 so off yeah I out in these
areas please support come by say hi to
the Lord Lord King don't have some
things cooking up for you as well so
that's gonna be good but I'm on that
note everyone enjoy their Sunday have a
good time and we're gonna kill this
thing man we out here peace